I have to ask you about the Larry
Sanders Show because that show it's such
an iconic comedy and in that show you
play Hank the the sidekick on the
program and you actually studied what it
took
you studied what it took it to be a
sidekick well actually yeah after that
five minutes was up what you do well I
actually went on the Garry Shandling
went on the Johnny Carson show and so I
I just sat up there where the were the
audience's to watch him and they did a
thing but what I did not know during mr.
Carson's monologue was that Edie I
wonder if anybody knows what I'm talking
about
it's Johnny Carson sidekick famously
McMahon McMahon yeah
but during the monologue ed was no more
than eight feet away yeah and he would
[Laughter]
he would laugh and then they did the
monologue it was over and they just the
lights went out and it's a two and a
half minute break commercial and they
bought both walked like ships of state
up to here yeah and they sat in I don't
know what you guys do but they sat in
complete silence they were both like
give up and I said I got it I understand
right and you do that cuz you over laugh
at his jokes
oh absolutely here's the fans here's
what I know here okay
here's one of the things I have one of
the thousand reasons I love Andy but one
is that he refuses to he does not fake
laugh so he will laugh occasionally if
he finds a joke funny right but if a
joke of mine bombs he stares at me like
everyone else and then got to do and
then picks on me on the air about the
joke and I actually think that's one of
the great things about the relationship
is that I can never if I can get Andy to
laugh I know it's real that's what I
love because I would my job would be so
much easier if any just went haha at
everything but yeah I'm I'm on their
side
yeah I insist you keep the quality ha
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography